Oh
Senor maverick at Wired and I want to
continue a conversation that Rick that
Chris Anderson kind of began this
morning when he talked about the
long-term trends in what we see in the
internet Chris mentioned three which was
this moved to video which we heard more
about moved to mobile and the move to
the cloud I want to take the same kind
of ideas but slice them slightly
differently and so if I could have my
slides they are what I would see is
three verbs for each
excuse-me six verbs that are transacting
through the future
and those six verbs are six major trends
the first one is this idea that we are
screaming we're not reading anymore we
are screening and we are screaming
because there are screens everywhere
literally we become no longer people in
the book we're now people of the screen
screens are filling our walls that's the
kind of workspace I want you can't have
too many screens you have screens the
backs of planes we have screens that
fill entire buildings now we have
screens that are next to us they're very
intimate that we're stroking and
caressing we have screens that are in
grocery stores I was filling up my gas
tank we see screens there we have
screens that are actually soon going to
be on our glasses that's the next
frontier spectacle screens that you see
through that you wear and that we can
see an overlay of the digital world on
to the physical world this augmented
reality which can slice in many
different ways so for the first time we
can actually see the disembodied digital
realm on top of the physical realm
that's the kind of screens that we're
going to and all these screens are kind
of converging in a certain sense we take
different media and we're making
basically one large media music if we
looked at a screen a blank screen we
could not tell what was going to be
shown on it is it a movie is it a
website is it a piece of text
that screen to show almost anything
showing that in some senses all these
many are converging in a certain way so
that's the first verb screening we are
now screaming everything and when we
screen things it's different screenings
don't have the same type of truth that a
book and an author and authority do so
we have to assemble our truth in a
different way so screening is the first
verb the second verb is that interacting
interaction is the key to the way we
interact with these screens so if you
watched a toddler with an iPad you can
loop which they quickly own so you're if
you have an iPad and toddler around it
quickly becomes a toddlers iPad they are
intuitively gesture oriented and they
can interact with these things to such
an extent that it becomes very obvious
that this is the new genre of dealing
with screens I had the story of a family
that had a iPad toddler and they left a
photograph on the counter and coffee
table and toddler came up and was trying
to do this to the photograph and was
saying it was broken because it wasn't
getting bigger just like it photographs
should there's an expectation that we
have interactivity with these screens
and you can see that kind of a sense of
the gestures that we see in Hollywood
depiction of the future of the screen in
Minority Report the time cruise
character is conducting the data like a
symphony we see it happening in Ironman
where they are trying to manipulate with
adjusters the the data and the user
interface is basically the whole body
not just the fingers typing we see the
same kind of thing happening with we
dance that voice is another way that we
interact with this screen that
long-expected interaction that voice I
think will become an over a 25-year
overnight success in the next five
we actually will have voice recognition
we can use those other senses the whole
body not just the fingertips and of
course all these things have eyes
everything has an eye built into it so
it's the senses of the eyes and those
eyes are looking at us as we watch the
screen okay so it goes two ways it's a
screen that we're looking into while it
looks out and we have things built into
a camera this is a laptop or a phone
that's watching us watch it and it can
track our eyes you can show where we are
giving it attention that's a heat map
showing the average attention given to a
website the more red it is the more
attention it is and that means that the
text or the film or the website itself
can adapt to how we're using it so if
we're having trouble understanding part
of it it can it can go deeper it can
recognize our mood whether we're paying
attention whether we're distracted
whether we're happy or angry and we have
the sense in which the content itself
can adapt to what we are watching or
screening so we have a sense in which
the interactivity is a primary function
of this world that we're headed into so
that's you might think of this as a
two-way mirror that where or to a window
where while we watch out it's also
watching in the third verb that's going
through this Internet as we move forward
is is the verb of sharing that is the
primary verb of this world the web was
built on sharing and it will continue to
go in that direction so we've heard the
terms of the cloud that's what the cloud
is it's a way to share the resources
that we're creating it's to share
everything not just the computers but
the data and the content as well so on
the cloud issue the issue the question
we have is that one cloud or many clouds
and that's something that's still being
resolved there's a private clouds or
public clouds is it a single humungous
global cloud or is it an Amazon cloud
and a Google cloud we don't know that I
suspect in the end it will be one cloud
but for the short term there may be
multiple clouds and the issue of being
the inter cloud the cloud of all clouds
will come up at some point one of the
things we know about clouds that have
Network effects and that is is that you
heard earlier talking about that wide
networks are so good the reason why
networks are so good is because a large
network is mathematically far more
valuable than a series of small networks
because the value of a network goes up
by the square of the number of members
and so a network that has a thousand is
far greater than two networks of 500 and
so that's why networks are so powerful
is because they have this mathematical
scaling property and so what we want is
we want to make as big a network as
possible to take small networks and
bring them together and things like
Groupon and others where we share making
networks of sharing it was just the
beginning everything that we know about
can be shared and these this is a list
of things that people said would not be
shared but in terms it turns out that we
are sharing them we're sharing them
because we can so we're sharing friends
we're sharing our location we're sharing
our investments we're sharing our health
records we're sharing their memories and
I suspect that in a certain sense that
anything that can be shared will be
shared that's where we're going in a
certain sense if you think about how
much can we share I think we're just at
the beginning of that I'm involved with
a group called the quantified self and
these are obsessive people who are
quantifying measuring self-monitoring
all kinds of aspects from their sleep to
their diets to their location to their
health parameters blood pressure
oxygenation levels all these kinds of
things and they're doing that because
they find that this is a way of
self-knowledge but of course in the
course of that to generating huge
amounts of data that have to be
understood and it's not just that
sharing it's it's everything and by the
way if you share that information your
health records and stuff or your own
quantify itself it becomes more valuable
and that's what we're discovering doing
it for yourself is one thing but then
you do it and then you share it it makes
it ten times more valuable you can you
can determine whether you're within the
range of others you can you can actually
use it as a way to bring value to your
own measurements because often times we
don't know what sort of normal is until
everybody does it on the meter of where
we are we've just begun to share things
so the next ten years is going to be
more of this as we find more things to
share more ways to share them more ways
to understand what we're sharing and I
think we're just at the beginning so
that's another way of understanding this
is that we're also going to have issues
about sharing that come from this and
the potential issue of course is privacy
and the related issues of personal
spheres that comes from trying to share
everything and and and I have two
metaphors I'd like to introduce about
sharing and in privacy and one is that
we have to understand that privacy and
transparency are very related and I
think there's actually kind of best
understood as a slider that what we want
what I want is I want people to treat me
as an individual but in order to do that
they have to know about me I have to
reveal myself to them and so if I am
revealing myself to them people can
treat me as an individual and if I want
to be maximally treated as an individual
then insert says they have to be
maximally visible so in a certain sense
of moving this transparency
of transparency and personalization if
we move it in one direction towards zero
where I have I'm not disclosing very
much about me
I'm not transparent but also I'm not
going to have a personalization with
with other people because they don't
know about me and in a certain sense we
can kind of real able that as private
and generic it's up so the cost of being
private is sort of you're going to get
generic services at the other end if we
slide it in the other direction we have
a lot of transparency and a lot of
personalization so in a certain sense we
can say that the ultimate
personalization requires ultimate
transparency and what we're finding is
in general people tearin tending to move
and push the slider towards the
transparent and personalization they
should always have the choice to slide
the slider in the opposite direction but
in general we're being surprised because
people are pushing it towards more
personalization and more transparency
so the second metaphor I like to
introduce this idea of symmetry and
knowledge and so the problem with we'll
have this stuff is that they know more
about us and we don't know who they are
and what we want to do is restore the
symmetry we're you know as much about
what other people know about you and you
and can correct it and can get some
benefit from it and to kind of restore a
certain balance a symmetry so that it's
more close to what it was like living in
a small town where everybody knew about
you but you knew about them and I think
if we can make it more symmetrical so
that I know but who knows about me and I
know what they know about me and I can
correct what they know and I get some
benefit then I think that feels better
to us so that's sharing the fourth verb
is flowing flowing is the new metaphor
there wasn't their first version of PCs
and computation borrowed the metaphor of
the desktop you had files folders
desktop and then we moved into the web
20 years ago and we had a new metaphor
which was pages and links in the
hypertext scene and that was the web
we're now into the third metaphor of
organizing our understanding of how
we're approaching this Internet and that
is we've moved to streams and tags and
the cloud and so everything is in a
certain sense in real time as we make a
stream of data in our own lives as a
quantified self self as we Life log as
we create a Twitter stream as we create
a RSS feed as we curate a Facebook wall
as we create Netflix streaming all these
things are streaming in real time they
have no past they have no future they're
just kind of a line going through and
that streams of things is really the new
metaphor and it's gone from we've gone
from pages two streams we've gone from
the claw PC to the cloud we've gone from
today today today to real-time now now
now we've moved from the personal me to
the Wii of sharing and the unit was a
page or an item and now it's data and so
a lot of the stuff is flowing earth
streams and flows of data and these
streams of individuals meet together and
where they meet that's an interaction
exchange and event and a media is in
some sense as a collection of all these
streams it's not really a unit a fixed
monumental artifact it's a bundle of
streams going through different people's
streams that are bundled together and
it's not of course just people
generating streams these streams of data
are coming from everything that we make
because we're putting a little chip of
intelligence and everything sending off
little streams wirelessly and there's
all these streams together that is
actually forming the new media it's
actually the new platform is not just
people it's actually all these location
devices sensors all creating streams of
data so it's everything and of course is
everywhere that we're aware of becoming
more so and of course it's always on and
that's
the other elements of this new media
this new Internet is that it's always on
so if it's not in real time it doesn't
count that's one of the lessons we take
from this streams have to be in real
time we have a shift to the real time
web that's the fourth the fifth verb is
accessing when we have this world where
everything is always there and it's
always on we have a new regime that's
possible we have this idea that we can
have access to things we can rent the
movie we can rent or have access to the
music Spotify you heard about Sean
Parker's Spotify the Amazon even
physical world we can do zip cars and
rentals if they're always there and
always on and that shift is is a huge
shift because it's moving us from
ownership to access the advantages of
ownership are diminishing and the
benefits of act has having access
instead are increasing and so we can see
things like just in time buying where
there really is no reason to purchase
something say on the Kindle before
you're going to buy it before you're
going to read it so it should only
purchase something five seconds before
you're ready to consume it because
otherwise it's it's just in the cloud
it's the same place that when you bought
it would be it's just in a different
category but it's just in the same place
when you have it and buy it what's the
difference you might as well wait until
you are ready to consume it and we see
that same kind of habit in Netflix where
more and more if it's not on the Netflix
streaming people don't watch it that's
like ourselves so we have this kind of
just-in-time purchasing which is almost
the same thing as not even owning it
access it is better you don't have to
store things you don't have to upgrade
them you don't have to maintain them you
know have to back them up why purchase
anything and I think we're very quickly
moving to the regime where you'll have
basically access to all music for a
subscription fee you'll have access to
all books Amazon basically a book will
not cost very much what you're going to
pay for as
a few minutes is really the reviews to
the book the access the navigation and
the movies are very quickly moving the
same way and I think wired included
magazines are going to become in the
same kind of a of a situation where you
are already subscribing to the magazines
you don't really own them
you'll only subscribe to this stuff and
you won't have to bother with the
burdens of ownership and I think this
will leak out into the greater retail
space where the the burdens of
ownerships will be seen against the
benefits of access so this is the last
verb and that's generating and
generating tried to deal with this issue
of well in this world of ubiquitous
always-on never owned content how do
people make money selling things how do
people make money making things and so
I'm suggesting that there's a shift to
the generation so the Internet is sort
of the world's largest copy machine
anything that can be copied at all if it
touches the internet is is instantly
copied in a kind of a super distributed
liquid it just flows through everywhere
and even when you send an email to
someone it's being copied multiple times
as it goes along so copying is what the
web does that's how it works
so how do you create things of value if
anything can be copied in discriminately
and I think the answer is this is that
the things that become valuable things
that cannot be copied easily so you and
so what you want to do is you want to
find things that can't be copied and yet
you also you want to make it really easy
to pay that's another side of it and the
very beginning was very difficult to pay
but you want to make paying the exchange
of money actually to be as simple and
easy as possible so you want to make
things that cannot be copied easily and
easily to pay I'm not going to dwell on
the easy to pay I'm going to talk a
little bit about the hard to copy so I
went to purchase I went to find old
issue of pre copyright issue of National
Geographic and I found this site that
would sell the
copy and which and but only if I wanted
immediately if I was willing to download
it for an hour there would no charge if
I wanted it right away I had to pay so
basically I'm paying for immediacy I'm
not paying for the thing itself I'm
paying to get it immediately if I wait
long enough I can get a free copy of a
piece of music or a film but if I want
to see it right now it's on release day
within minutes I'm going to pay and
again I'm paying then for the immediacy
rather than for the content we see the
same kind of a thing happening with
personalization yeah you can get that
piece of music for free but if you want
to personalize tailored to the acoustics
of your living room you will pay for
that personalization even though the
same Symphony would be available for
free somewhere and the same thing can
happen with books we can personalize
them or anything else the other thing we
that's hard to copy is authentication so
yeah you can have a peek
you can find free software out there it
might be exactly the same software is
the one authenticated we're paying for
authentication almost like a kind of
insurance but it's something that cannot
be copied you cannot copy authentication
by definition we find the same kind of
thing that's hard to copy with
findability so actually what we're gonna
pay Amazon for is the ability to find
something if you have if right now we
can fit every bit of music that has ever
been recorded in the world onto six
terabytes of music in the next year two
years will probably fit on something
this size that's only $600 but the
question is what are you gonna listen to
next if you have every piece of music
everywhere what are you gonna listen to
next and answering that question is
actually very difficult and something
that people are willing to pay for being
able to find something and sometimes we
want the embodiment so a lot of the
bands are making their money by selling
their physical embodiment as a
performance and the music is a copy that
you can get is sort of a type of
advertisement for that embodiment and
there's another
when we're understanding what you get is
really valuable so the old saw and the
software industry was software is free
but the manuals a thousand dollars
understanding how it works is something
that is worth paying for
and so accessibility as I described
earlier is another way having access to
it is valuable even though all the time
in real time when you want it that is
more valuable oftentimes than just
getting it for free
the last one is patronage where people
actually want to have some kind of
contact with the creator and are willing
to pay as a way to make a connection
with the author so these are all
generative --zz it has to be they came
copy and have to be generated in the
context of the experience of exchange
and because of that they are valuable in
this new economy they are the real
drivers of value so I call them
generative because they have to be
generated in context with an exchange in
the context and I think they are part of
this movement to wherever attention is
flowing money's going to follow so let
me just wrap up the six verbs the first
is screening so everything is moving to
screen screening is a verb that we
understand interacting if it's not
interacting it doesn't work interaction
is what drives our screening abilities
everything has to interact sharing is
the main verb and we've just begun to
share everything that can be shared will
be shared flows instead of in streams
instead of pages or desktops
everything is streams and flows
accessing is more important than
ownership and finally generative as a
way things that cannot be copied their
heart a copy has a fundamental economic
unit so I think those are I think
the six main ways of slicing what's
happening alongside in the mobile and
the video and the cloud and whatever it
is we know that we're you're not late
okay we've just started this we're just
at the beginning so thanks for your
attention